the second installment of a docu-series
about disgraced R&B star r kelly
premieres tonight on lifetime in
surviving r kelly part two the reckoning
we hear from accuser Dominique Gardner
she appeared in the first lifetime
documentary seen by nearly 30 million
people now Gardner is sharing her story
for the first time on camera r kelly
faces sex crime charges in New York and
Illinois those charges include child
pornography transportation of minors and
racketeering our Kelly pleaded not
guilty and is in federal custody
awaiting trial the last two years where
I felt like I didn't want to live
anymore
it was dark the new docu-series tells
the story of our Kelley accuser
Dominique Gardner Gardner now when her
late 20 says she spent nine years with
art Kelly before leaving him last spring
I could not get the door dan it's my
mother my camera crew
she says she left Joycelyn savage one of
Kelly's current so-called girlfriends
behind it was hard for me because that's
not my heart don't leave people hanging
people are very concerned by people I
mean your parents last March
Gayle King interviewed savage and
another alleged r.kelly girlfriend as
real Clary can you both communicate and
see your parents whenever you want yes
yes of course we can but we choose not
to because of what the things they have
done out here to the world saying they
would be inhale capital became sex slave
accuser faith Rogers also appears in
this series hey text and phone cause I
had to change my number Rogers says she
was 19 when she met Kelly at a party
after a concert in Texas two months
after they met Rogers claims Kelly
recorded them having sex without her
consent and knowingly gave her a
sexually transmitted disease Rogers says
she left Kelly after about a year and
filed a lawsuit against him we first
interviewed her in May of 2018 he asked
me how old I was and I told him and he's
like you know if you're really you know
16 that you can tell daddy right and
again last January I'm finding my
strength and I'm pressing forward with
everything I need to do Kelly
emotionally defended his innocence
regarding all sex abuse during an
exclusive interview last year with Gayle
King faiths lawsuit against our Kelly is
still pending are Kelly's attorney
released a new statement in response to
the accusations from faith and Dominique
it said quote I have not seen the show
surviving our Kelly part two so I do not
know what lies and district and
districts cues me distortions they are
planning to air but both of these women
are simply out to exploit their past
connection to our Kelly look at their
social media they are not victims
they are prophetess
you